بينما ينشغل الغالبيه في تامين احتياجاتهم
الغذائيه في رمضان من خلال الاسواق
والشوادر والمعارض هناك فئه من السيدات
ينتظرن مثل هذه المواسم فهم يصنعن عددا
كبيرا من المنتجات المختلفه بايديهم
ويستهدفن شهر رمضان كاحد مواسم الرواج
احنا ابتديناها فيسبوك
للستات اللي عندها مشاريع صغيره
وبيدوروا على طريقه يسوقوا بها منتجاتهم
دي فاحنا عملنا جروب الستات بتخش وبتدخل
صحابها عشان زي ما قلت لك المنتجات عندنا
ليها طبيعه كده والناس بتعمل حاجات بقيتها
فبتعملها ليها علاقه بمثلا
مناسبات عامه دائما السيزون الحلو بالنسبه
لنا هو الشاب سيزن العالي اللي هو كريسماس
رمضان
قبل الصيف على طول السيزنس دي بتبقى
عايزين يشتروا حاجات ربما يتراجع وجوده
مثل هذه المعارض خلال فتره الكورونا
ولكنها عادت بقوه خلال الماضي والان تشهد
رواجا لدى فئات بعينها قادره على شراء في
ظل الظروف الصعبه الكورونا يعني كانت هي
اكبر فلوس لنا يعني قعدتنا في البيت
فالناس بتشتري اون لاين فالحمد لله الدنيا
كانت ماشيه كويس قوي لما ابتدينا بقى ننزل
للناس تاني بعد ما المعارض رجعت طبعا فرق
جدا برضو الحمد لله
الناس بقت بتشوف الحاجه على الطبيعه
روح المعرض نفسه هتشتري مني هتشتري من
غيري كنا بننزل قبل كده بحاجات ملونه بس
لقيناه الناس حابه كلمه رمضان كريم على
الحاجه يعني في حاجات تانيه باعت اقل لما
الناس بتاعه تحس ان احنا مش هنخرج يبقى مش
هنشتري لبس
وجولري واكساس وكده بس الدنيا بقى ان كل
الحمد لله خلاص ابتدا ان هو الناس ترجع
وتبقى عايز تشتري حاجات مختلفه وكده لا
تكاد تمر عطله نهايه اسبوع خلال شهر مارس
الا وبها عدد من المعارض والبازارات التي
تخاطب فئات او فرحات في الدخل تنتشر في
شرق وغرب العاصمه حيث فرص اصطياد منتجات
مميزه لشهر رمضان قائمه وبشكل افضل من
الشراء عبر الانترنت من وجهه نظر الكثيرين
تامر نصرت العربيه القاهره